welcome back well in the last video we
took the Maclaurin series for cosine of
X the Maclaurin series representation so
I guess we might as well do the same for
sine of X and I I'm sounding very
nonchalant but I have a a reason behind
why I'm doing this and you'll see in a
few videos from now when we come with
the when we come up with the grand
conclusion so anyway let's just set f of
X and you might just want to do this
yourself and instead of watching me do
it because it should be pretty
self-explanatory now with now that you
saw a cosine of X but and then you could
check your work you polish right now and
then you can check to see that we got
the same answer and you'll probably be
right and I probably made a careless
mistake so f of X is equal to sine of X
so first of all let's just figure out
all of the derivatives of sine of X and
we can already guess and it probably
cycles similar to cosine of X slight
variation so what's the derivative of
sine of X well that's just cosine of X
what's the second derivative I'm just
going to stop any parenthesis around
these numbers the second derivative well
that's just derivative that it's minus
sine of X the third derivative of X well
I guess I'll put the parenthesis so you
don't think it's f to the third time's X
the third derivative well that's just
going to be the minus cosine right
because the derivative of sine is cosine
then we have that minus sign there then
the fourth derivative well derivative
cosine is minus sine but we have a minus
there so we get back to sine and then
the cycle continues and so the fifth
derivative is just going to be cosine of
X or just the derivative of sine of X
and then the cycle will continue right
all right so we know the derivatives and
we could just keep going so let's
evaluate the derivatives of our function
of sine of X at X is equal zero so f of
0 f of zero well that's sine of zero
what's sine of zero well sine of zero is
zero
f prime of zero is equal to cosine of
zero well that's equal to one
the second derivative at zero that's
minus sine of zero well sine of zero is
still zero so that's zero you can see
it's a very similar pattern to what we
saw in the Maclaurin series for cosine
of X and then the third derivative
evaluated at zero that's cosine of zero
is one we have a minus sign so it's
minus one this you already know the
fourth derivative is zero sine of zero
is zero and then it starts to cycle
again the fifth derivative zero equal to
one so we start with zero then positive
one then 0 then minus one and zero then
positive one so every other number is a
zero every other I guess you could say
coefficient in the Maclaurin series is a
0 the coefficient when you don't include
the factorial term and then the ones in
between oscillate between positive 1 and
negative 1 so what would be the
Maclaurin series for sine of X the
Maclaurin series representation so we
could say that sine of X and remember I
haven't proven to you that the Maclaurin
series representation of sine of X or
cosine of X or e to the X really is
equal to those functions over the entire
domain I might do it a later frankly
I've been thinking about the proof
myself I haven't it hasn't been
completely intuitive how to do that
proof although if you if you test them
out it does seem to make a lot of sense
but you shouldn't just take my word for
it I'm going to look up the proof and I
will prove it to you eventually but for
now you just have to take it as a bit of
a leap of faith that the Maclaurin
series representations just don't
approximate those functions around zero
that when you take the infinite series
it actually equals the function so the
sine of X the Maclaurin series
representation is going to be equal to
well f of 0 well that's 0 plus F of so
the first derivative it's going to be 1
times X to the 1 over over 1 factorial
which is just 1 this is just 1 and then
we have this is just plus 0 and then we
have minus and now where this is the
third derivative right so minus 1 times
X to the third
over three factorial then you have a
zero and then we have a plus one now
this is not a fifth derivative so X to
the fifth over 5 factorial now we'll
just keep going but I think you see the
pattern and so we ready to rewrite it
sine of X is equal to zero so we get X
to the first so that's just well X minus
X to the third over 3 factorial plus X
to the fifth over 5 factorial and then
you can imagine the pattern we'd go -
we're just taking the odd numbers X to
the seventh over 7 factorial plus X to
the ninth over 9 factorial minus X to
the 11th over 11 factorial and we'll
just keep going right and so we're where
we'll just keep oscillating in time it's
not in in sine interesting that's a bit
of a pun and we use all of the odd
exponents so if I were to write that in
Sigma notation I would say well that
equals and Sigma tation often is the
hard part well once again let's see the
first term when the term is zero
well when the this is the first term
right and we get a positive sign so we
want because we're going to oscillate in
sign we'll probably take negative 1 to
some power so it'll be negative 1 to the
n plus 1 because we want every so let's
see if that works if this is the first
term this will be a no no that won't
work it'll be the to the 2n plus 1 and
actually I think I should have done that
in the previous video - I think it
should have been negative 1 to the 2n
not negative 1 to the N I'm sorry for
that mistake right so it's negative 1 to
the 2n plus 1 times X to the X to the 2n
I don't know sorry I was right in the
previous videos yeah I'm I'm confusing
myself because I don't count the zero
terms
so let me probably help me to write the
Sigma down first so this is equal to is
equal to as you can see I do all of this
in real time infinity from N is equal to
zero and so the first term is positive
so it'll be negative one to the N right
because negative 1 to the zero power is
1
all right so that's positive and then
the second term is negative then
positive negative right times and so
what is the 0th term is is x so it has
to be X to the let me see 2n 2n plus 1
does that work right because the first
term would then be 3 right X to the 2n
plus 1 over 2n plus 1 factorial it's
almost easier when you just write it out
like that well that's pretty interesting
but what's even more interesting is if
you see the similarity between the
Maclaurin series representation for sine
of X and then the representation we
figured out for Co svet cosine of x in
the previous video we figured out that
cosine of X is equal to 1 minus x
squared over 2 factorial plus X to the
4th over 4 factorial minus X to the
sixth over 6 factorial plus X to the 8th
over 8 factorial so they're almost the
opposite right they almost complement
each other the cosine these are all of
the even exponents right and even
factorials and sine is all of the odd
exponents and all and because you this
is X to the 0 right because so that's
why you get one here and in sign it's
all of the odd exponents and all of the
odd factorials in the denominator so
that by itself should i think is pretty
neat and and what what is especially
neat it just
another you know fodder for thought is
that we know from trigonometry that sine
is just a shifted cosine function or
that cosine is just a shifted sine
function but what's neat is by shifting
it by PI over 2 which is all they are
right if you were to graph it they're
just shifted 90 degrees to the left of
the right of each other you can actually
represent them differently by
essentially picking the odd or even
I guess terms of kind of this this
factorial of polynomial series whatever
you want to call it but anyway it
doesn't matter if you didn't understand
what I said at the end as long as you
appreciate how cool this is I will see
you in the next video